[Music]
you know
you got to be very now i think some
people thank you trash pandemon thank
you guys for all the support
i think a lot of people are looking for
the one book
that's going to propel you to the next
level and
that doesn't exist there are chess books
that are amazing and
really really good for various reasons
but
you know if you want to improve
genuinely you're going to have you're
going to
if you want to improve using chessbooks
you're going to have good experiences
with books you're going to have books
that you read and they don't give you
that much everybody has their own
particular pathway and you have to make
a good faith effort thank you for the
500 and the 100 jesus
to engage with these books and here's a
couple of tips on
engaging with chess books so let's say
we have
a let's say you want to improve your
positional play in your 14 1500 now
there's a couple of specific
recommendations i have my all-time
recommendation for club players
on positional chess is a book called
chess strategy for club players by
herman gruden that's
an international master from the
netherlands it's a long big thick book
i don't have it in print form but it's
it's a full
compendium of positional concepts
phenomenal stuff
of course i've written a book on
positional chess far from the best
mastering positional chess
there's also the comp what i have at
hand is the complete manual of
positional chess
it's the two volume series it's it's by
two russian grand masters it's a little
bit mis-titled
because you know some of it some of the
chapters are on tactics
it's also basically an encyclopedia of
positional concepts but it's more
fun it's not as dry as an encyclopedia
and you know like the first volume is
separated into
part one the opening part two the middle
game
and you know the opening has the
following chapters advantage and
development the center and its
significance
do not make unnecessary pawn moves if
you have not completed your development
and the middle game has chapters like
prophylactic thinking prophylaxis
schematic thinking regrouping one's
forces
okay so let's flip to a random section
this is in english
schematic thinking all right so let's
say you're reading a book
reading a chess book a lot of people
they go you know into the process of
reading a chess book
wanting to put a check mark next to the
box that says i've read this book
and you want to you want to keep in mind
why you're reading the book
and it you have to be reading the book
with the express purpose of
wanting to take as much information
that's in the book and
funneling it into your brain i think i
i i have been guilty of this reading
this book and patting myself on the back
and saying well i read 30 pages today
like i read 40 pages of the karpov book
like look at me
but then i would ask myself who am i
doing this for and did i
learn 40 pages worth of material or did
i just put a check mark next to it
and i always try to catch myself on that
so
when you're reading a chess book i like
to use a physical board
but you can also use your computer you
can use a virtual board you can use a
lead chess board
so let's let's say i'm using a
chess-based board
you know you set up every position so
let's start reading chapter 15
schematic thinking regrouping once
forces transferring pieces to move to
more favorable positions
okay now i always have a notebook with
me when i'm reading
books chess books and in the notebook
this is not my actual notebook you would
ideally write down you know stuff that
you find helpful general conceptual
stuff that you find helpful
you know tips you know maybe very
instructive games
another reason instructive games you
find in the book that you want to review
later
you want to engage in many different
ways with the book so that
information persists in your brain in
positions
that are not filled with tactics one can
often form short-term plans to fulfill
strategic objectives
for example a player may think the rook
would be good on that square the knight
on that one and the bishop on this
having does determine his plan he can
choose the most accurate way of carrying
it out
okay and the authors give the following
position
and i've i've read this book before so
i've seen this position let me set it up
for you guys and then i'll i'll give you
guys this position as an exercise it's
it's not easy this is like 17 800 plus
level but still instructive
okay so this is from the game geller
literally pologayevsky against geller
riga1958
okay yes geller
yes ethan geller
so uh pologayevsky geller
and it's white to play in this position
the authors
write the following so far black has
managed to contain
white's central play
so far black has managed to contain
white central play thanks to the
blockade on e5
okay so the word blockade is important
here it's just like a pawn or a piece
that's
acting as a stop gap um
but white retains the advantage because
the knight on a5 is far away from the
center okay that makes sense
if it if it stood on d6 or e5 in the
event of the pawns there being exchanged
black's position would be very pleasant
so a good way to
engage with that sentence would be to
say okay let me try to understand why
would black's position be pleasant so if
you're doing this in a physical world
it's very easy to reposition the pieces
okay so let's imagine you know a
scenario where
knight appears on e5 like does it make
sense to me you might ask that black's
position is very pleasant here
well it should make sense because this
knight isn't in is amazing it's an
eternal night it's on an outpost right
and it's pressuring c4 so clearly this
is a positional gain for black
so this should make sense and the same
goes for d6 if black's knight could
appear on d6
um that's a you know beautiful
blockading square the knight is the best
block gator it immobilizes the deep on
it pressures the e pun
okay so this makes sense um
so now they give white's move and if you
really want to take this to the next
level you would
essentially play guess the move with
most of these positions you can read a
chest book and not
force yourself to try to find the move
but if you want you can sort of cover
the move with your hand and stuff
and some of the good books will have
exercises for you at the end
then you really don't have to do it so
the question is how does pologoyewski
get things to happen in the center
favorably
because if he doesn't do anything geller
is going to get his knight to d6
and he's going to stabilize the
situation so urgency is required and
urgency is required with respect to this
e5
this is the pawn which white needs to
target i think that's pretty obvious
from the position
how do we target that can we do anything
with
our resources as they currently are
i'll give you guys a second to think
about this this is a very instructive
position
okay it's whitetail so
i'll give you guys a second to think
yeah and people are super sharp i'm very
happy to see this
the correct move is knight c1
exclamation mark
yep knight c1 is a brilliant positional
move the knight transfers to d3
from where it strengthens the pressure
on the key square e5
once the once this blockading point will
fall black will be in trouble
at the same time white's last move also
opens the second rank
so his rook can transfer to the king's
side
geller desperado mode f5 he tries to
complicate the position but pologowski
just goes knight d3 anyway
the key here is to target the e5 but he
doesn't care about that pawn
and after e takes f4 comes another very
instructive move
very instructive a white to play it
seems like there's a lot going on here
but
in reality there isn't if you if you
zero in on the key aspects of the
position
beautiful great job e5
if you have the tendency to recapture
automatically that might be something to
notice
if e5 catches you by surprise you might
ask yourself why
well maybe it's because black you know
this requires the sacrifice of a pawn
it's quite clear that this is worth you
know these connected passers in the
center is worth sacking a pawn over
but if this caught you by surprise that
would be a good thing to write on your
notebook like
you know i have a tendency to recapture
automatically
i'm going to try to fight that or
whatever so in this way you make these
observations you learn this stuff
the game ends pretty quickly queen g5
okay so we attacked the pawn
very patient move by poligayevsky
doesn't have to rush with these pawns
the pawns will go eventually knight f4
um knight takes c4 desperado
night sacrifice and another
very patient move you could just take
the knight and
you know you could win with the move d6
jack but
geller or sorry pologoyevsky plays
e6 advancing the pawn intermediate move
attacking the bishop
knight takes b2 e takes d7 attacking the
rook
rook d8 and yet again this is a game of
intermediate moves
what does white do in this position do
we take the knight or is there a better
move
yeah knight e6 is crushing 96 fork
queen f6 now it takes takes
boom boom boom rook to d6 forced
otherwise this pawn would have promoted
knight b7
and the final move of the game
essentially is
what just i mean exquisite play by
pologovsky every move is precise
and this move wins d6 and black resigns
because
in comes bishop c6 followed by d7 and d8
okay and they go on to the next position
so in this book like they
don't spend too long on any given any
one position
but they give a lot of instructive
positions some books
they take the opposite perspective
they'll give four or five positions per
chapter but they'll spend like
you know three the positions themselves
will be more complicated
this is the complete manual of
positional chess it's the two volume
series
and uh as a coder with a tin boo
damn coder 10 gifted this guy gifted 20
yesterday he's on madman
thank you coder
damn girl
wow nice very very nice it's easy to
understand when i explain it to you well
good books will do a good job explaining
it to you
um and
you know there's more complicated
examples as the chapter goes along so i
want to give you guys if you don't mind
one more example
of of this uh of this let me go back to
the speed run
scene so i can set this up i want to
give you one more example of
of uh five bucks from don seneca okay
um so this is from the game la laco
against adams peter leicko against
michael adams
from 2002.
so lanco adams and this is the same
chapter schematic thinking
each white piece is more active than its
counterpart and one hardly needs to say
anything about the pawn structure
black's pawn structure is riddled with
weaknesses
two paths are possible now but the
chosen in the game
is the most technical and the most
convincing over the board
after asking himself the question of
which of his pieces can be improved
further
laiko found the answer dean madden thank
you for the prime
now that's a question i've asked many
many times during the speed run i've
advocated that
you ask it but in some positions
it's hard it's a hard question to answer
and
certain positions can be very misleading
because you look at all the pieces and
it's hard to say which of the which of
the pieces needs to be improved so i'll
give you guys a second to think
but lego finds a brilliant positional
idea here
which i really i find this to be a very
powerful example
um in in many different ways so
let's think about this for a second
there's several good moves here white is
better so there's not going to be just
one
good move but i think he finds the best
move i'm gonna
eat a ferrero rocher as you guys are
torturing over this position
okay
so this is very tough
all right let's convene now there's two
main ideas
that white can orchestrate here let's
begin with the one that didn't happen in
the game
i'm very impressed that how many people
understood
that g5 might be a very powerful pawn
break
and the way to set this pawn break up is
to move sorry not bishop d3
but to move the bishop all the way back
that's the only good square
now why not c2 because why would you put
the bishop on a square
where it's in the line of fire of the
rook whoops i cannot draw a single arrow
instead you want to go bishop b1 that is
the move he didn't play
and as the authors explained there is no
satisfactory defense to the powerful
threat of g5
now let's say you read this in your
single i don't get why g5 is so strong
well just play around you know you can
use the engine but you can skip a move
and say okay so if white plays g5 why is
this so good okay so you have to attack
the knight
black has to take okay so white takes
can't get fate now let's say you're
thinking here okay what does white do
here well what seems obvious in this
position
i'll get to f4 in a second
rook hay now that's not checkmate but
after king e7
you can give another check on e5 the
point here is that you're trying to
disattach the king from the rook do you
have a way to disa chat disattach the
king from the rook here
the move is very easy the king is the
worst defender it is the easiest piece
to check
the bishop comes back from the dead
check on f5
king has to move up and you win the
rogue that's a pretty smooth line
yeah rookie seven exactly that's right
man
so it's pretty easy to determine why g5
is devastating and black is too tied up
to do anything about it
now to the concept of f4
why is f4 an inferior way to prepare g5
there's a couple of things to understand
about using your pawns to prepare stuff
when you push a pawn i can't emphasize
this enough you have to look at the
squares that you weaken
right and this creates a gaping hole on
e4 now you might say well well i get it
but the bishop
guards that square but it's still a weak
square and even if black were to play 94
immediately
jettisoning upon you would still uh
oh actually no the pieces the bishop
bangs the true you can't play knight e4
that's
that's a good point but how can black
try to trade the bishops
so that knight e4 becomes possible
what's a move that comes to mind here
so bishop d7 comes to mind and you could
very easily end up in a situation
where you're allowing this central
counter play without having to
so this might be a good lesson you might
write down in your notebook okay
when i move pawns ask yourself which
squares are weakened or which squares
are
accessible to my opponent's pieces and
try to prepare stuff in a way that
doesn't weaken
squares but the move that
uh that laco played is knight to c2
incredible uh positional awareness
now where the hell is the knight going
it's that's even hard to say after you
see this move
what he's trying to do is do a little
switch
he wants to bring the knight to e3
then move the bishop away and then play
knight f5
forking the king in the h6 pawn
so he started by identifying the
weakness which is the h6 bond
and both of the correct solutions
involve
doing something with that weakness this
involves attacking it
no i mean this is hard and min found a
very similar idea knight a two knight c3
so knight c2 exclamation mark
rook to e8 by adams and lanco just
ignores him 93 this rook is
perfectly well defended you don't need
to do anything with it
knight ce7 rook c7 now the king steps in
to protect the work notice how adams is
is uh sorry how laiko is not going at
four he doesn't want to weaken the e4
square he doesn't want to give black
anything
now after bishop c6 the bishop steps
away
leko has no choice but to go bishop d7
trying to cover the square but now the
other idea comes in
and adam's simply resigned his position
just collapses
either this pawn is going to collapse or
he's simply going to get checkmated
much like we saw in the game right
so and the line that he gives that um
that the authors give by the way after
bishop c2
they oh sorry after bishop b1
they give bishop d7
and then oh and then just knight takes
d5 so that's another thing to point out
so it's a super complicated idea and i
think what people
fail to understand sometimes they look
at this and they say
not to put words in everybody's mouth i
feel like i'm doing that a lot you might
say well i would never find social ideas
and what's the purpose of reading about
this
i understand this idea like once you see
i think everybody should understand this
idea
once you see it how would you ever find
something like that how do you know
that the knight is the piece that needs
to be improved when it appears that the
knight is precisely the strongest piece
it's tying black down to d5 so
and that's there's no good answer but
the more of these examples you see the
more of these maneuvers you acquaint
yourself with
the likelier it is that you're going to
pull yourself by the bootstraps
eventually you're going to see something
like this yourself
and maybe you can make some insights
about this the knight is not doing
enough
the knight is only doing one thing and
it's tying black down to d5
but you don't need to tie black down to
d5 black is already tied down
so the knight is is um is redundant
it's like the flight engineer you don't
need um
you don't need the knight anymore on
before maybe it was serving a purpose at
one point
but now i can see greener pastures
cinderella thank you so you can spend
30 minutes on this one position and say
that's my reading for the day
which is why when i have students
particularly kids who say
how many pages did you read this week
150
no way you retained even five percent of
what's in this 150 pages it can take you
two three months
to read a book like this and that's fine
you'll retain a lot more than somebody
who reads it in a week and we go for the
g5 one because it's closer to the king
yeah
because you know you can identify the
king as being weak it's
you know weak because the pawn structure
around it is bad we've got
major piece domination thank you
cinderella so it stems from that then we
might try to orchestrate
attacking ideas
yep my system is is another book that's
like you know
it's like sipping absinthe or something
you know you got to do it slowly
and and and you got to savor every drop
or black caviar reading positional books
is like the black caviar of chess it's
like you don't want to eat a whole
sandwich full of it
you want to savor it bit by bit
sorry to ramble so much but and you do
this with every chapter space advantage
there's a lot of good stuff in this
right the varetsky same thing but i
don't really recommend varesky for club
players for the most part
frictious asks can you explain why
advanced openings aren't recommended for
beginners i mean at the beginner level
nobody knows twenty was a theory anyway
yes
absolutely so
the the simple reason is that there's is
precisely what you say
to play those advanced openings well you
need to memorize a lot of theory
why is that an inherent negative for a
beginner because when you're a beginner
your goal is to master the principles
behind the moves not
necessarily to memorize a bunch of moves
and openings like the grunfeld
require you to understand stuff to such
a degree that you know when to violate
the rules
grunfeld gives up the entire center so
everything hinges on your ability to
memorize all this theory
and you want to play openings where
there's a little bit of memorization but
that's stress
concepts like the queen's game declined
where you don't have to violate as many
opening rules
i'm glad to hear that pickle sardines
there's no one book for silman is good i
think jeremy stoman is a little
overrated his end game book is really
good though
his end game book is phenomenal
yeah okay
well this has turned out to be much
longer tutorial session than i
expected but i'm enjoying it
well i would say 45 i mean if you you
just need to understand how much time
per week you have
i mean this is basic planning like if
you have three hours to dedicate to
chess a week
okay maybe an hour of that will be
reading
and perk not
really i i don't generally recommend the
perk tit really to anybody
yes playing a lot of bullet is
definitely pernicious to beginners in
the long run
how to reassess your chest is good it's
it's one it's a good book it's
it's not a must read but it's a good
book
you're right exactly deserved that's
exactly right
well at this point i haven't studied
chess too much but
a good amount i i used to study nothing
crazy during
my school years i would train an hour a
day or so
but i would do that over the course of
many years
yeah so when you're a beginner 15 minute
is great
as long as you analyze your games if you
can analyze your games carefully
you will have a good time uh you will
you will derive a lot of benefit from it
chess strategy for club players i would
say well for people your level alone
yes now another book that i'll recommend
to everybody very heartily
and something that is that really flies
under the radar if i if i'm
i can share some secrets in my
laboratory
yeah houston is great but helstone is is
a little bit more against that's for
like 2 000 rated players
um i'll be right back
so
so a couple of things um deboratsky's
mark moritzky's disciple grandmaster
arthur yusupov has his
a very good book series chess evolution
and another book that i've been really
enjoying recently
and using a lot for my students is
uh improve your chest pattern
recognition it's by
dutch i am is a great you know he's very
reputable 2014 so
this book has been around but man this
is like
so full of of really good material
really good material which is well
explained and
um honestly i love books that just have
a lot of good examples you know i like
this format one page for example
lots of good stuff stuff you can really
take away and
and learn from so that would be another
recommendation
the more games you can funnel into your
brain the better the more
material you can you can marinate in
the better yeah
improve your chest pattern recognition
at some point i'm going to make like a
library of recommended books i'm not
there yet
no i've talked about opening study
and i think that's actually a recipe for
failure to ignore opening study until
you're 1800
some of the recommendations are in the
mubarak command
but it'll take me some time to assemble
that that library i don't i don't just
want to like
put random recommendations and stuff
and i still want to create courses and
stuff you know like
there's so much that i want to do chess
teaching wise it's just that
all of this requires like a lot of
effort to assemble and
right now i'm just enjoying doing this
stuff on stream
i think when i'm a little bit older
maybe a couple of years from now i'll
start focusing more on
producing courses and sort of creating
more of a legacy but right now i'm just
enjoying the impromptu kind of stuff
all right
which one of the manual of positional
chests they're both good now i would
just read both that they're
they're different one builds on top of
the other
thanks guys this was a great
instructional segment i think i had a
lot of great time
so yeah uh complete manual positional
chess
and uh we're going to stream tomorrow
for sure
i'm not sure exactly exactly when
uh thank you guys is awesome i'm really
happy to see
how how people are improving and i
couldn't couldn't ask for a better for a
better crowd so
thank you guys
[Music]